serene and duncan smith who's supporting
liz trust well firstly you must be
delighted with the result yeah i'm very
pleased uh our candidate liz trust put
on 27 extra which was the biggest growth
of all of the three candidates
and she's through now to the round with
the public to the members so that's very
good news she's bought a very good
campaign i'm
sorry the others have fallen out we're
all conservatives at the end of the day
i hope we'll all come back together
again and just get on the government as
and when whoever wins the final round
you just say you know there that we're
all conservatives we need to kind of
pull together and beth ripley was just
making the point that i guess liz trust
and rishi sunak have really been getting
stuck into each other a little bit in
those tv debates so whoever wins is
gonna have in her words a hell of a job
turning it around we always say that
i've done seven of these one two and one
one myself and everybody always says
will you come back together again and
almost always we come back together
again i mean these debates are big
debates and i think the public has a
right to hear them what are you going to
do about helping people who are
suffering from the cost of living crisis
should we get taxes down do we need to
have such high taxes i don't think so
these are big debates that the public
needs to see us and recognize we're
passionate about and we may disagree on
some of these things but at the end of
the day we have one person all
conservatives want to get the basic tax
down the question is when do you do it
but you also will acknowledge as you
know you are you know a veteran if you
like of some of these debates that there
have been a personal attacks i mean you
for example have been
you know told me about penny more than
what she's done for the last few years
we've seen lord frost for example
questioning her comments there have been
clearly
a tax page they're not personal attacks
if you ask i want to know i mean i uh
judged everybody on what their record
was in government over two and a half
years you had two and a half years to
deliver brexit get things done who did
the most who actually managed to get
those across the line and i went to lose
trust because she had the strongest
record on it
my question about penny morton was i
don't know what she's done she needs to
be clear about what her successes and
failures were how did she battle things
over that's all so just a reasonable
question that's not an attack on anybody
do you think the tone of the debates
will soften in the months ahead over
some of them well i think they'll be
they're going to be tight because
it's a very important job and the
direction of the party and the country
will depend on who wins it
so
my view is that they will be quite
fierce
but i don't think they're going to get
personal i don't think you know i would
advise everybody
policy yes
debates about how you do stuff but stay
off the personal stuff on the policy
though we now have two very very
different visions of how the uk should
be run uh on the ballot paper don't we
uh we have uh rishi sunak and liz trust
and if you look at everything from you
know taxation to spending
we can't be ending up with two very
different visions of britain well there
are differences but their differences
really of emphasis and of timing
even rishi soon act says he wants to
bring taxes down but he doesn't believe
you do it now i disagree with him i
think he's got the headroom to do it liz
believes that
there are economic commentators out
there that actually agree with us and
some that agree with him
this is a serious debate to be had
because people's lives depend on what we
now do so i think these are legitimate
debates
the whole conservative party wants to
bring the base of taxation down the
question is when and how you do it which
is what's going to be debated uh what i
do want to ask you now is that the next
prime minister is going to be decided by
conservative party members
somewhere between 160 000 or 200 000
people right
whoever wins should they not call a
general election so they then have a
mandate to implement their vision which
as we know is going to be quite
different from the mandate the manifesto
of the last days no because
we don't have a presidential system here
so we have a parliamentary system
the prime minister is only the leader of
the party while he holds their
confidence
we've had this going down hundreds of
years where they don't hold their
confidence they have to go and somebody
else who has the confidence of the
political party that was elected in this
case conservatives
has a right to see out that term so i
don't think a general election is either
wanted or warranted what we need to do
is go to the next period for two years
have the election then people can judge
us on what we've done i thought we lost
two and a half years because of the
covid crisis now we have to get those
things sorted out
be madness to go to an election i know
some people will say an election tall
people want elections all the time some
people but the answer is you need
stability right now and that's what this
is all about how concerned are you that
as the you know country faces the cost
of living crisis you know there's a war
in ukraine
and now we really have a bit of a vacuum
in august uh as british sooner and liz
trusts slug it out
well there's lots that can be done right
now by the government still run by boris
johnson there's huge things they've got
on their agenda they can do and there's
lots they can do to help people out in
the meantime
this debate will come to fruition at the
end of august and what will happen is a
new administration
but now with a different type of energy
and focused on the things that we want
the decisions about taxation are what
this is really all about
how do we make the most out of brexit
get the regulations down get the base of
taxation down get the economy growing
you mustn't have this economy going for
a recession it'd be utter disaster with
high interest rates so that is where we
go now that's a debate worth having and
i certainly am looking forward to this
talk about high interest rates that you
blame risky scenic partially for i blame
i blame the
the government of the bank of england
really because i think they took their
eye off the ball they were printing
money a year ago
which was ridiculous and inflationary
and they didn't do interest rates do i
blame the treasury in part
because uh they shouldn't have signed
off on the on the on the monetary on the
explosion of qe which took place it
should have been stopped but
these are judgment calls they'll all
come up in the course of the debate just
finally it was really quite tight at the
end wasn't it between liz trusts and
penny morgan can you give us a bit of an
insight into what the last 24 hours has
been like at hustling up support
well you know here you see everybody
face to face so
um everybody who is not sure would have
been seen they might have been seen by
liz trust or by penny mordent or by
wishes
and then one by one they decide what
they're going to do and they do it some
people don't always tell the truth most
do
and that's how it is so it's been hard
draft
and
and i think liz was always coming from
behind she put on 27 votes which is a
very significant proportion and is now
in the in round two and i think that's
that's great because it means we have a
proper debate now okay a proper debate
uh certainly in markets thank you very
much for your reaction there ian douglas
smith former leader of the conservative
county